en accueillant cette fin d'après-midi la
ministre des Sports des Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques sur les crédits
budgétaires de son ministère dans le
cadre du projet de loi de finances pour
2023 lorsque vous avez pris vos
fonctions madame la ministre il y a
quelques mois maintenant le monde du
sport était encore en train de penser
ses plaies suite à la crise sanitaire
des interrogations existaient sur le
redémarrage des inscriptions dans les
clubs et sur la pérennité de certains
clubs professionnels la situation semble
aujourd'hui plus favorable il faut bien
entendu s'en réjouir le monde du sport a
plutôt bien résisté à la crise sanitaire
et plusieurs dispositifs adoptés par
l'État ont aidé à passer ce cap le
projet de loi de finances pour 2023
reconduit plusieurs de ce dispositif
c'est notamment le cas du passeport qui
permet d'accompagner le processus de
reprise des licences dans les clubs mais
également du plan en faveur du
développement des équipements de
proximité géré par la ns qui permet de
renforcer la diversité de l'offre
plus généralement les crédits accordés à
l'Agence nationale du sport sont
préservées tandis que la solideo
poursuit son programme de construction
des ouvrages olympiques sans retard
notable dans ces conditions la hausse de
3% des crédits consacrés au sport
constitue une bonne nouvelle même si les
moyens devraient être en baisse en
termes réel compte tenu d'une inflation
qui pourrait être d'au moins 4,3% en
2023 selon les prévisions officielles
nos inquiétudes madame la ministre
porteront donc davantage sur la suite
compte tenu des incertitudes qui
entourent l'année 2023
quels seront vos marges de manœuvre si
la situation économique venait encore à
se dégrader compte tenu de la hausse de
l'inflation et de la récession mondiale
attendue au dernier trimestre 2022 et au
premier trimestre 2023 est-ce que le
monde du sport pourra résister à une
nouvelle tempête je vous propose dans un
propos liminaire de nous présenter les
principales orientations de votre budget
après quoi je céderais la parole à notre
transporteur Jean-Jacques lozac puis un
chacun des groupes politiques à travers
un de leurs représentants et enfin
chacun des chacune des synatrices et
sénateurs qui souhaiteraient intervenir
pour vous poser la question sans plus
tarder dans la ministre c'est de la
parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs d'abord merci pour cette
introduction stimulante je suis très
heureuse de pouvoir m'exprimer devant
votre commission à nouveau chez le
plaisir de vous de vous retrouver et en
effet pour dresser un tableau du projet
de budget que je porte pour le ministère
des Sports des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques à travers les programmes
219 sports et 350 pour les jeux
peut-être trois caractéristiques pour
introduire ce projet de budget le
premier c'est souligner qu'il atteint un
niveau inédit avec
un virgule 113 milliards d'euros de
crédit en progression de 1,8% par
rapport à ce voter en loi de finances
initiale pour 2022 et qui marque au
global ainsi sur la période écoulée des
5 ans une progression de 50% du budget
sport à périmètre constant crédit qui
sont passés de 481 millions d'euros en
loi de finance initiale pour 2018 à ce
PLF pour 2023 la deuxième
caractéristique c'est que je crois que
ce projet confirme en effet le soutien
de l'État aux politiques publiques du
sport en France puisque vous l'avez dit
monsieur le Président avec 818 millions
d'euros de moyens qui leur sont dédiés
nous sommes en progression de près de 3%
de virgule 6 exactement 818 millions
d'euros qui se décomposent entre 652
millions de crédit budgétaires et 166
millions d'euros de taxes affectées le
troisième la troisième caractéristique
c'est que c'est aussi un projet qui
s'agissant des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de Paris 2024 présente des
moyens que je crois pouvoir qualifier de
maîtriser de conf à nos engagements avec
un total de 295 millions d'euros de
crédit qui eux se décomposent en une
tranche de 270 millions d'euros pour la
solideo intégrant une nouvelle code part
au titre de l'inflation celle revenant à
l'état à hauteur de 71 millions d'euros
mais aussi une tranche de 25 millions
d'euros de financement pour le comité
d'organisation au titre de la
contribution de l'État au jeu
paralympiques vous vous souvenez que
cette contribution elle est de 80
millions d'euros au total pour l'État
étalé sur trois années et compléter par
10 millions d'euros versés par la Ville
de Paris et par la Région Île-de-France
pour porter l'ensemble à 100 millions
d'euros
alors dans un dans un contexte où les
jeux sont évidemment un levier tout à
fait majeur inédit pour donner à notre
sport la place qu'il mérite dans notre
société que ce soit pour la jeunesse la
santé le bien-être de nos concitoyens
mais aussi l'insertion l'inclusion
sociale
la progression des crédits du programme
219 souligne très clairement la tension
portée à nos politiques publiques
sportives et ce à travers plusieurs
éléments que j'aimerais rapidement
brosser le premier c'est la poursuite du
plan équipement sportif de proximité
un plan dont vous vous souvenez que il a
été porté par le Président de la
République le 14 octobre
2021 avec une première tranche de
financement qui était de 100 millions
d'euros dans l'exercice qui s'écoule qui
ont permis d'ores et déjà de financer
2000 équipements à travers le pays
et nous engageons maintenant une
nouvelle enveloppe de 100 millions
d'euros qui marquent et j'y reviendrai
notre volonté d'accélérer sur la mise en
oeuvre de ce plan sur les 84 millions
d'euros qui ont été dansaient déjà
investis pour ces 2000 équipement je
voulais souligner que au global 18% un
petit peu moins de 20% donc avait
bénéficié à des équipements en qpv un
petit peu moins de
78% en zone rurale et 2 à 3% pour la
partie outre-mer
le deuxième élément et vous l'avez
évoqué dans votre introduction monsieur
le Président c'est la consolidation du
Pass sport avec une nouvelle enveloppe
là aussi de 100 millions d'euros pour ce
dispositif avec à la fois l'exigence que
nous avions d'une expérience digitale
simplifiée sur la plateforme
passeport.gouv.fr de procédures de
remboursement accéléré pour les clubs
qui jouent le jeu les structures
éligibles qui se rendent éligible sur la
plateforme le compte asso et également
point majeur du dispositif qui vous est
présenté un champ de bénéficiaire étendu
à un petit peu moins de 800 000
étudiants boursiers des boursiers de
l'état des boursiers qui sont
attributaires d'une aide annuelle du
CROUS ou qui sont éligibles au crédit
pour les étudiants des formations
sanitaires et sociales des régions
ils pourront ces étudiants boursiers
bénéficiaient à titre expérimental dans
deux académies Créteil et Lille de la
faculté donc non seulement comme tous
les autres jeunes éligibles d'aller dans
un club sportif mais aussi de s'abonner
à une salle de sport de fitness privé
puisque nous travaillons en partenariat
avec le secteur des loisirs marchands
troisième élément saillant 4 millions
d'euros sur le sport santé pour
finaliser le maillage des maisons sport
santé les stabiliser autour de 500
d'entre elles et entreprendre vraiment
de consolider ce dispositif qui à la
vertu vous l'avez en tête à la fois
d'accueillir un certain nombre de
publics éloignés de la pratique sportive
et de l'activité physique mais aussi de
mieux mettre en réseau les
professionnels de santé du secteur
social du secteur sport et de l'activité
physique adaptée
je voudrais également quatrième point
souligner trois mesures nouvelles qui
viennent conforter nos actions en amont
des Jeux Olympiques la première
s'inscrit dans une logique de soutien à
la haute performance et de
fortifications de notre modèle sportif
avec 3 millions d'euros incrémentaux
pour l'accueil des grands événements
sportifs internationaux d'ici les jeux
le deuxième élément s'inscrit dans une
logique d'engagement et vise à associer
dès à présent les Français à l'élan
populaire à l'élan des jeux avec 5,5
millions d'euros de crédit dès 2023 au
titre de la billetterie populaire qui
consiste en un ensemble de 400000
billets qui seront offerts pour les
séries les cérémonies d'ouverture où les
épreuves pour trois grands publics de
bénéficiaires que sont la jeunesse y
compris le public scolaire les bénévoles
du mouvement sportif à hauteur de à peu
près 100 000 d'entre eux et les
personnes en situation de handicap ainsi
que leurs aidants et puis la troisième
de ces mesures nouvelles s'inscrivant
dans la logique amont des jeux c'est une
mesure
héritage qui porte sur le renforcement
de 10 millions d'euros du budget socle
de l'Agence nationale du sport au titre
de ces politiques de soutien à l'emploi
et à la professionnalisation des
structures sportives vous avez en tête
que dans le cadre de France relance une
action assez vigoureuse avait été menée
en cette direction qui avait notamment
permis le financement de 7500 emplois
d'éducateurs ou d'agents de
développement dans les associations
sportives de nos territoires
un autre élément pour compléter ce
tableau et celui du renforcement des
moyens humains du ministère et de ses
opérateurs en effet dans le projet de
budget qui vous est soumis il est
proposé 5 emplois de plus sur
l'opérateur kelinspe l'Institut National
de la performance et de l'expertise sur
la haute performance en vue des Jeux
avec un passage de
562 à 567tp pour l'ensemble des
opérateurs du ministère et sur l'INSEP
strictosensu nous passerions de 277 à
282 ETP le deuxième élément de ce de
cette consolidation des ressources
humaines du secteur sportif c'est la
stabilisation des effectifs de cts à
1442 ETP et avec une amélioration de
leur formation de leur formation
continue grâce à un soutien nouveau à un
dispositif qui s'appelle l'école des
cadres le tout important sur une
enveloppe au titre sur le au titre du
titre de
90 millions d'euros et puis je voudrais
mentionner en complément de cette
enveloppe de titre 2 les 20 postes
supplémentaires dans les services des
concentrés Jeunesse et Sport consacrés à
la lutte d'une part contre les violences
à caractère sexuel et sexiste mais aussi
contre la radicalisation dans le sport
un point de grande vigilance pour mon
ministère et ses services déconcentrés
le point que je souhaiterais également
aborder dans ce tableau introductif
c'est le fait que pour concrétiser notre
ambition
nous avons
[Musique]
consacré beaucoup d'efforts beaucoup
d'énergie quasiment depuis le premier
jour de ma prise de fonction à inscrire
notre action dans un cadre de
gouvernance amélioré clarifier
renouveler avec une articulation bien
améliorée entre l'ensemble des partis
prenantes du sport en France et tout
particulièrement entre la direction des
sports de mon ministère et l'agence mais
aussi au niveau des territoires où nous
avons tous en tête que se joue une large
part du dynamisme de notre modèle
sportif et je voudrais souligner à ce
titre l'installation des 13 conférences
régionales du sport de l'Hexagone plus
de la majorité de celles d'outre-mer
d'ici la fin de cette année 2022 avec
les projets sportifs territoriaux qui
avancent bien une installation en cours
des conférences des financeurs et des
projets structurants qui commencent
désormais à être bien reprisé au sein de
chacune de ces conférences régionales du
sport
cette dynamique de clarification des
rôles et des responsabilités elle est
guidée par l'exigence de mieux allouer
les moyens et de garantir une dépense
publique plus efficace ce qui est
évidemment un enjeu clé quand on a en
tête la structuration du budget et du
programme de 119 puisqu'il prévoit que
sur les 818 millions portés par ce
programme 430 millions soit 52%, soit
affectés à l'Agence nationale du sport y
compris les 166 millions d'euros de
taxes affectés donc je le disais gros
travail fait sur cette gouvernance la
volonté de bien réaffirmer le projet
commun de l'agence pour très bien
redéfinir son rôle et son positionnement
la nécessité en parallèle de bien
redéfinir les missions de la Direction
des Sports autour d'un triptyque
l'orientation stratégique des politiques
publiques leur évaluation mais aussi le
régalien couvrant la lutte contre toutes
les formes de violence dans le sport
en complément de ces deux initiatives un
travail fait sur les protocoles de
relations de travail entre ces deux
entités et un tableau descriptif des
missions de chacun qui est désormais
achevée et qui préparera le terrain pour
une révision de la convention
d'objectifs et de moyens pour la période
triennale qui va s'ouvrir
s'agissant de l'agence
mention d'abord de son action au titre
de la haute performance avec un
engagement très fort des équipes autour
du programme ambition bleu pour les 650
athlètes qui se présenteront aux Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques et pour
lesquels l'agence qui est en train de
préparer son projet de budget pour
l'année prochaine consacre d'ordinaire
autour de 120 millions d'euros ce qui
est un montant à peu près équivalent à
celui investi par la Direction des
Sports sur ces sujets à travers les
CREPS et à travers l'INSEP le deuxième
pan de l'action de l'agence vous l'avez
en tête c'est à travers le programme
impulsion sport tournée vers le
développement de la pratique et qui lui
fait l'objet d'environ 310 à 320
millions d'euros de financement
le dernier élément que je voudrais
mentionner dans cette introduction c'est
que cette amélioration de notre
gouvernance porte déjà ses fruits on le
voit dans une série de réaménagements
que nous avons apporté au plan 5000
équipement de proximité que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure qui ont pu être acté lors
du conseil d'administration du 6 octobre
dernier et qui a permis un élargissement
du zonage avec une prise en compte de
l'éligibilité maintenant de tout nos
territoires avec une priorisation sur
les territoires carencés mais qui ne se
limitera plus
occupé ou bien aux zones de
revitalisation rurale et à l'Outre-mer
France entière maintenant est éligible
des mesures également de simplification
des dossiers et de l'instruction par les
dragées et l'éligibilité aussi des
dépenses dites de design actifs qui
permettent d'agir sur le mobilier urbain
et notre cadre de vie pour inciter à la
pratique sportive
le plan de sobriété énergétique nous
venons d'adopter le 13 octobre dernier
est également un signe de cette
alignement meilleur plus fort plus
compacte des acteurs où chacun jouera un
rôle important l'agence le ministère des
Sports et l'ensemble des acteurs
notamment le sport professionnel engagé
à nos côtés dans ce travail structurel
je voudrais terminer cette exposé en
mentionnant les quelques échéances à
venir l'atelier que j'organiserai lundi
matin prochain avec Olivier du soft et
Carole Grandjean sur l'insertion sociale
par le sport celui que nous aurons le 5
décembre prochain journée mondiale du
bénévolat sur cet enjeu majeur pour nos
3,5 millions de bénévoles pour lequel
nous avons vraiment besoin de préserver
la vitalité de ces acteurs engagés
contribués aussi à les rajeunir et à
féminiser ce secteur du bénévolat ainsi
qu'un atelier dont j'ai pu faire
l'annoncière soir à l'occasion de la
Parisse Games Week consacrée à à
l'horizon du 12 janvier prochain vous le
voyez je crois que nous avons au global
toutes les cartes en main pour
contribuer et avancer dans notre
ambition de faire de la France une
nation plus sportive à l'heure des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques avec une
ambition qui est claire à la hauteur de
nos responsabilités sur le régalien un
budget consolidé une gouvernance
améliorée et des programmes qui se
déploient sur les territoires
première question de notre rapporteur
Jean-Jacques Lauzac
bien merci
la parole est à Jean-Jacques Lauzac
rapporteur des crédits merci monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre merci pour
la précision de vos propos je l'ai vu
très par une observation générale en
effet avec vos priorités ministérielles
clairement affirmées et pleinement
justifié et le mode de fonctionnement
que vous avez décidé pour le modèle
sportif l'été dernier vous avez posé je
dirais les fondements les soubassements
d'une politique sportive convaincante
mais le grain de sable bien sûr dans ce
bel ordonnancement c'est la trajectoire
budgétaire
et je dis trajectoire je n'insiste pas
sur tel année très précise comme 2022 ou
2023 trajectoire est d'ailleurs nous
sommes là je dirais pour vous aider à
l'améliorer cette trajectoire budgétaire
en effet la France organise à Paris en
2024 le plus grand événement sportif du
monde mais également le plus grand
événement tout court jamais organisé
dans notre pays
on le sait officiellement depuis 2007
notre candidature était déjà officielle
et déclaré en 2015 et depuis sur toute
cette période les lignes budget
et puisque nous sommes toujours autour
de 0,2% des dépenses du budget de l'État
donc depuis une décennie
et je n'oublie pas par ailleurs parce
que on pense que tous les équipements
sont des équipements à pérenne avec une
vocation sportive pérenne qui a un
certain nombre d'équipements sportifs
type village olympique ou centre des
médias qui
deviendront une fois les Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques derrière nous des
programmes immobiliers ma première
question dans l'étude nationale sur les
attentes et les besoins des acteurs du
sport qui étaient rendus public au mois
de mai dernier à la question quel
revête-être les priorités pour la
gouvernance collégiale du sport pour les
5 à 10 prochaines années ces acteurs du
sport répondent massivement deux
orientations
la première c'est l'accès de tous les
publics à l'activité physique et
sportive et deuxièmement la construction
la rénovation l'accessibilité des
infrastructures sportives deux
orientations qui rejoignent pleinement
d'ailleurs l'héritage olympique
ne pensez-vous pas que pour financer ces
priorités si on reste dans le cadre des
taxes affectées mais on peut toujours
demain changer de cadre si on reste donc
dans ce cadre des taxes affectées au
sport le moment n'est-il pas venu c'est
un petit peu ma marotte je veux dire de
solliciter davantage les mises des paris
sportifs en ligne qui ont explosé je
rappelle de 44% d'un an et 200% en 5 ans
et ses paris sportifs n'existeraient pas
bien évidemment sans leur support c'est
à dire le sport qui n'existerait pas
sans le bénévolat ou bien encore en
remontant le plafond de l'une ou l'autre
des deux autres taxes affectées soit la
taxe buffet soit les les jeux qui sont
gérés par La Française des jeux ou bien
encore je dirais leur déplafonnement
deuxièmement la discussion du projet de
loi de programmation des finances
publiques pour les années 2023 à 2027
actuellement en débat cet après-midi au
Sénat a révélé que le gouvernement
prévoyait de baisser les crédits
consacrés au sport à l'issue des jobs de
2024 en effet les crédits qui
s'établissent 1,8 milliards d'euros en
2023 devrait baisser 1,6 en 2024 et 1,5
en 2025
comment expliquer cette baisse alors que
les besoins demeure immense la hausse
récent des crédits dans la perspective
des Jeux Olympiques n'aura-t-elle été
qu'un feu de paille
troisième question la dégradation de la
situation économique est bien évidemment
un impact sur la préparation budgétaire
des JO et il est essentiel que le
Parlement soit informé en temps réel de
la situation Carine Finet c'est le
contribuable français qui est en quelque
sorte quotient solidaire le kojob semble
avoir du mal à boucler son budget
pensez-vous qu'il est encore possible de
maintenir les équilibres du budget
initial soit en rechargeur de nouvelles
économies ou bien encore faut-il se
préparer à un déficit
quatrième question concernant les
infrastructures olympiques en effet une
enveloppe supplémentaire de 50 millions
d'euros devraient semble-t-il être
financés par les collectivités
territoriales pourrait-elle contribuer à
cette hauteur je pense notamment à
pleine commune comment comptez-vous
faire face à cet éventuel difficulté des
collectivités et enfin une dernière
question le plan France relance adopté à
la sortie de crise sanitaire avait prévu
des crédits afin de renforcer
l'isolation thermique des
infrastructures sportives cette
enveloppe d'ailleurs même été consolidée
en 2022 pourtant ces crédits ne sont pas
reconduits dans le PLF 2023 alors que le
plan de sobriété énergétique les remplit
nécessaire que jamais comment expliquer
cette volte-face merci
je vais vous proposer de répondre
d'abord à sa première série de questions
puis après les autres sénateurs
interviendront
peut-être
je pense que incontestablement
on a rendez-vous en 2024
avec un examen d'efficacité sur notre
politique sportive et notre modèle
sportif
moi je le dis toujours quand j'entends
parfois le CNOSF vouloir se réunir sur
l'avenir qu'il a par la suite je dis
souvent mais l'avenir va être
étroitement lié à ce que nous allons
montrer aux Français en 2024
donc il y a un examen dont nous sommes
absolument tous conscient pour autant je
suis persuadée que dans le travail que
nous menons aujourd'hui sur l'héritage
sur les grands événements sportifs
internationaux
il y a des éléments de durabilité
qui font du sport
une valeur d'avenir incontournable dans
les modèles sociaux
que nous construisons
pourquoi parce que on est aujourd'hui à
un moment où la sédentarité à un coût
estimé à 17 milliards d'euros ou
l'inactivité à un coût estimé à 140
milliards d'euros ou la prégnance des
écrans abîme
en partie le quotidien et parfois les
capacités cognitives et d'équilibre de
vie de nos enfants leur hygiène
tout ceci fait que ce que nous engageons
aujourd'hui par exemple en faveur du
sport
autour et à l'école
sont des transformations durables de
notre modèle et qui ne s'arrêteront pas
quoi qu'il arrive au lendemain des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques les 30
minutes d'activités dont on a vu enfin
Landes où elles ont été expérimentées
qu'elles étaient bonnes pour lutter
contre l'obésité infantile qu'elles
amélioraient les capacités cognitives de
nos enfants qu'elles étaient propices à
créer un habitus favorable à la
consolidation d'une pratique sportive
dans la durée ça ne va pas s'arrêter
demain c'est quelque chose que nous
consoliderons et que nous allons
d'ailleurs de mieux en mieux animer à
travers les territoires quand nous
cherchons à travers un dispositif comme
les deux heures de sport en plus pour
nos collégiens à jeter des ponts
nouveaux entre le monde de l'éducation
nationale des chefs d'établissements et
les éducateurs sportifs dans nos 180 000
structures associatives là aussi c'est
pour guider les cultures c'est pour
créer cette coopérations nouvelles avec
les collectivités territoriales avec les
parents d'élèves qui complètent ce
dispositif et d'ancrer durablement ces
compléments Ludo sportif qui vont nous
permettre de lutter contre le décrochage
d'un certain nombre d'enfants au moment
de l'adolescence et particulièrement des
jeunes filles tout ceci venant compléter
les 5,6 milliards d'euros que nous
investissons dans le PS qui reste le
socle fondamental du sport à l'école
ainsi que dans le sport scolaire avec
les trois heures prévues pour nos
professeurs de PS au sein au cœur de
l'UNSS
tout ce dispositif là qui aujourd'hui
monte en puissance continuera de monter
en puissance
un autre élément est relatif au sport
santé ce maillage que j'évoquais de nos
500 maisons sport santé cette mise en
réseau de nos professionnels de santé le
travail qui est fait sur la formation
initiale des médecins sur la formation
continue des médecins avec cette faculté
qui est désormais donnée non plus
seulement au médecin généraliste mais
aussi aux médecins spécialiste de
prescrire une activité physique adaptée
plus seulement pour les malades de
maladies chroniques ou d'affection de
longue durée mais aussi pour les
personnes en situation de perte
d'autonomie ce sont des évolutions
sociétales fondamentales qui nous
permettent en complément des
expérimentations au titre de l'article
51 de la LFSS avec par exemple des
dispositifs comme retrouve ton cap qui
aujourd'hui sont en train de monter en
puissance et de faire la démonstration
que le sport aide à traiter des maladies
diminue les risques de rechute
accélèrent la rémission en faisant cette
démonstration là c'est des éléments
durables pour placer l'activité sportive
au cœur de notre modèle de société et
l'année 2024 dans lequel le président de
la République a fixé le cap en faisant
de cette année celle de la grande cause
pour l'activité physique et sportive
c'est sûrement pas pour s'arrêter le 31
décembre 2024 autre élément de la
durabilité du modèle que nous
construisons c'est celui des grands
événements sportifs internationaux ou le
calendrier aujourd'hui
ne s'arrête pas le 8 septembre 2024 au
soir de la cérémonie de clôture des Jeux
paralympiques mais au contraire nous
permet aujourd'hui d'engranger des
victoires dans des candidatures assez
grands événements jusqu'en 2027 je pense
par exemple à
au championnat du monde de cyclisme où
vous savez que le département de la
Savoie accueillera cette grande
compétition en 2027 et je voudrais
vraiment saluer encore la victoire des
équipes
derrière cette candidature quand on
regarde le calendrier les championnats
d'Europe de natation en 2026 un certain
nombre d'autres compétitions de cycrocla
de cycroc de cyclo-cross tout ce qu'on
va faire aussi dans des disciplines
populaires comme le badminton sur le
judo tout ceci on inscrit un calendrier
de grands événements sportifs et un
soutien à ces grands événements dans la
durée
de l'évolution des crédits sur 24 et 25
quand on regarde la courbe hors titre 2
ces crédits sont censés passer de 728 à
628 puis 589 mais je précise que cette
présentation du budget sur trois ans
dans nos documents budgétaires qui
d'ailleurs une nouveauté elle est
présentée à titre indicatif et donneront
lieu évidemment à de nouvelles
discussions à de nouveaux arbitrages il
y a un effet mécanique qui joue entre 23
et 24 qui est lié à la fin du programme
des équipements sportifs de proximité
mais vous l'avez parfaitement exprimé
monsieur le rapporteur dans votre dans
vos questions et dans votre remarque à
vocation à prendre le relais le plan de
rénovation thermique des équipements que
nous avons inscrit au cœur de notre plan
de sobriété énergétique
sur ce sujet là je voudrais faire
vraiment la démonstration de la
dynamique qui est en cours en rappelant
que sur la première enveloppe de 50
millions d'euros de crédit qui ont été
mobilisés pour cette rénovation
thermique nous avons d'ores et déjà pu
financer 166 dossiers en 2021 donc 84%
en zone carencée et 20 en outre-mer avec
une diminution moyenne projetée qui est
de 48% de la consommation énergétique
annuelle des équipements concernés
au global nous avons des projets de
l'ordre de 300.000 euros qui bénéficient
d'un 300000 euros de subventions taux de
subventions de l'ordre de 42%, et trois
familles d'équipements qui ont bénéficié
de ce mouvement qui sont les salles
multisports les bassins de natation
ainsi que les terrains de grands jeux
ces travaux ils sont mis en œuvre
évidemment en lien avec les porteurs de
projets à la fois public les
collectivités et nous allons poursuivre
cette dynamique à travers la seconde
tranche de 50 millions d'euros dégagés
sur 22 et 23 où nous avons déjà à date
46 dossiers qui ont été déposés 54
millions d'euros de subventions
demandées et un effort qui va se
poursuivre de manière très intense dans
les semaines à venir je voudrais
compléter ce tableau de la dimension
rénovation énergétique des piscines dont
on sait que c'est un enjeu
particulièrement important 12 millions
d'euros ont d'ores et déjà été dédiées
au financement de les éléments par
l'Agence nationale du sport avec 30
projets qui ont été soutenus et la
volonté que nous avons de continuer cet
effort non seulement au titre des
crédits de l'ANS mais également dans le
cadre des synergies que nous voulons
trouver avec le fond vert qui vient
d'être annoncé par le gouvernement pour
accompagner les collectivités
territoriales sur cet enjeu à hauteur de
2 milliards d'euros
il y a dans le plan de sobriété que vous
avez rappelé d'autres mesures
structurelles que j'aimerais pouvoir
rappeler et notamment l'encouragement à
la signature par les gestionnaires des
infrastructures sportives des contrats
de performance énergétique qui vont là
aussi permettre de bénéficier de
certains financements et qui permettront
d'améliorer à travers la pose de
panneaux photovoltaïques la réflexion de
l'éclairage à travers des systèmes de
génération de chauffage d'installation
de pompes à chaleur d'amélioration de la
ventilation de travailler sur
l'efficacité énergétique de nos
équipements en partenariat avec
l'ensemble des acteurs concernés
alors s'agissant maintenant des des
taxes affectées c'est un point qui est
évidemment très important
plusieurs fondamentaux dans le projet de
budget qui vous est soumis me semble
aujourd'hui respecter d'abord dans une
logique de sincérité
on a pour la taxe buffet une mise
finalement du plafonnement au niveau du
rendement attendu de cette taxe là vous
savez que
le décalage avec des rendements
finalement inférieurs à ce qui avait été
autorisé en pleine fondement nous ont
obligé au cours des deux exercices
passés de procéder à des mesures de
régulation en gestion en finançant sur
les crédits du ministère des Sports des
compléments de ressources pour l'agence
qui n'avait pas la totalité des recettes
qui étaient prévues donc on s'inscrit
d'abord dans cette logique de sincérité
ensuite sur cette taxe buffet nous avons
une affectation qui reste de 100% au
sport et une compensation intégrale sur
les crédits budgétaires de la révision à
la baisse du plafonnement qui tient
compte de médias pro et de ses suites
logiques sachant que la rénovation des
des droits du nouveau cycle de contrat
de droits de diffusion pour le foot et
notamment la Ligue de foot professionnel
se fera courant 2023 on garde aussi en
partie le bénéfice du relèvement de ce
plafonnement par rapport aux exercices
2020 2019 2018 donc ces améliorations
qui avaient été apportées à l'époque on
en garde aussi une partie du bénéfice
s'agissant de du prélèvement sur les
paris sportifs en ligne
en effet nous sommes aujourd'hui sur un
plafonnement qui est stable à 34,6
millions d'euros ce qui fait que le
dynamisme un petit peu supérieur attendu
ne bénéficiera pas au sport mais au
budget général de l'État il viendra
financer d'autres éléments critiques
notamment le fonctionnement de nos
services publics de notre système de
santé de notre de notre école le même
raisonnement valant pour le point des
des jeux exploités par La Française des
jeux hors des paris sportifs nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans la réflexion sur
comment
bénéficier d'une partie de ce dynamisme
de ce dynamisme là et c'est également
des échanges que nous avons pu avoir
avec le rapporteur spécial dans le cadre
des travaux à l'Assemblée nationale
s'agissant des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques vous avez raison de
souligner que notre exercice budgétaire
qui traverse des semaines critiques
puisque nous devons atterrir sur ce
sujet-là au conseil d'administration du
COJO le 12 décembre prochain est un
exercice donc difficile délicat et
soumis à différents vents contraires le
premier de ces vents contraires et celui
de l'estimation de l'inflation
aujourd'hui
on est dans une enveloppe qui sera
probablement
autour je dis ça avec beaucoup de
précautions puisque les estimations sont
en train d'être affinées mais
supérieur à ce qu'on a pu enregistrer du
côté de la solideo et de ses 150
millions d'euros puisque à la différence
de la situation qui prévaut pour la
solideo 50% des marchés du Kojo restent
à conclure donc il y a une exposition
structurelle qui est plus forte
pour le comité d'organisation et ce que
nous sommes en train de regarder de de
peigner de manière fine
c'est l'estimation puisque en fait cette
révision budgétaire pluriannuelle elle
date la dernière date il y a deux ans en
décembre 2020 c'est le chiffrage très
fin des écarts qui ont pu être liés qui
ont pu être liés à des évolutions du
projet je pense par exemple à la
cérémonie pour les Jeux paralympiques
aux évolutions aussi apportées à la
carte des sites il y a également la
nécessité de tenir compte de la
complexité de certains cahiers des
charges je pense aux events delivery
modèle donc vous savez que Paris 2024
essuie un petit peu les plates c'est une
nouvelle dimension du concept du CIO
autour de l'organisation de ces jeux
également des éléments liés à la
sécurité privée dont nous savons que
c'est un métier en tension avec un
accord récent visant à valoriser pour
valoriser les salaires dans cette
filière et également différentes
difficultés opérationnelles je vais en
donner une très concrètement juste pour
illustrer le propos quand on organise
des épreuves au Grand Palais on a besoin
par exemple d'occulter la verrière pour
tenir compte des exigences de
retransmission c'est un élément de
complexité de cahier des charges qui
n'avaient pas été vu qui n'avait pas
anticipé qu'il faut donc chiffrer et
pouvoir intégrer à la copie un autre
élément qui lui n'avait pas été
actualisé dans la révision de décembre
2020 c'est celui afférant à la masse
salariale qui est donc un point
d'attention important là aussi à
fortiori dans le contexte 1 d'inflation
que nous connaissons et deux de tension
sur ces marchés là sur ces expertises là
à un moment par ailleurs nous organisons
la Coupe du monde de rugby et donc ces
expertises sportives sont très
sollicités sur le marché
également nous aurons besoin de
travailler avec le CIO que nous verrons
la semaine prochaine sur quelques points
de difficultés dans les apports en
nature de nos partenaires top c'est à
dire les tops partenaires du CIO puisque
l'ensemble des financements qui forment
le 1 milliard 4 que c'est partenariats
représentent sont parfois avec une
composante en nature dont on doit
s'assurer qu'elles puissent bien être
utilisée par les équipes du Kojo à plein
et quand des difficultés se présentent
qu'on puisse bien négocier avec ses
partenaires pour trouver des solutions
en phase de ces vents contraires de ces
points de difficultés on travaille
évidemment aussi sur le volet recette
pour continuer à aller chercher de
nouveaux sponsors et notamment aussi
pour optimiser nos ressources de
billetterie donc vous l'avez compris on
est très au travail sur cette enjeu là
avec en amont du conseil
d'administration du 12 décembre un
bureau exécutif qui permettra de
partager avec l'ensemble des parties
prenantes la ville de Paris le conseil
départemental de Seine-Saint-Denis la
région Île-de-France et qui tôt nous
permettra d'examiner les voix et moyen
d'un budget qui devra de toute façon
être le plus proche possible de l'équipe
je l'ai dit lors de mon audition du 12
décembre nous aurons certainement pour
cela besoin de mobiliser une partie de
la réserve pour aller à nous devrons
aller chercher de nouveaux partenaires
nous devrons avoir des discussions
fructueuses avec le CIO de la même façon
que nous devrons procéder à des
arbitrages parfois difficiles douloureux
courageux en matière d'économie à
réaliser sur le budget du Kojo
je vais maintenant passer la parole à
représentant par groupe en commençant
par Michel serin
merci président madame la ministre je
vais commencer mon intervention par
peut-être
trois ou quatre points positifs
les points positifs que que vous nous
avez présenté c'est la stabilisation du
nombre de postes de cts sur lequel le
Sénat était fortement mobilisé il y a
quelques années
l'autre point positif et c'est plutôt un
retour sur les cinq postes manquants en
ligne 7 qui
sur lequel nous avions alerté l'année
passée
au moment du vote de budget la
suppression des cinq postes ces 5 postes
donc reviennent à l'INSEP c'est une
bonne chose les 20 nouveaux emplois
aussi qui ont été dégagés dans les
affaires de violences sexuelles et sexy
ainsi que la radicalisation des
départements c'est un point aussi
positif et enfin la décision que l'on
appelait nous ne veut déjà dès le départ
de lancement de l'opération des
équipements sportifs de proximité
allaitendre à l'ouvrir à l'ensemble des
territoires je crois qu'il était
incompréhensible pour certains
territoires ruraux de se voir exclus de
ce dispositif et vous l'avez entendu et
ce qui a été validé par l'Agence
nationale du sport maintenant mais les
interrogations par rapport au budget que
vous nous présentez vous parlez vous
avez évoqué le passeport vous affichez
l'objectif cette année de dépasser les 2
millions de bénéficiaires avec mes
extensions
aux étudiants boursiers
mais qu'en est-il aujourd'hui à l'heure
on se parle du nombre de passeports
quand on sait que en 2022 l'enveloppe a
été consommée à 60%
deuxième question il est constaté un
recul de la pratique de actif physique
de l'activité physique dans le
secondaire avec un essoufflement du
déploiement du label génération 2024
lorsqu'on fait le tour dans les au
niveau des académies malheureusement ce
dispositif à encens et pas au point
d'arrêt mais vraiment une petite vitesse
de croisière que comptez-vous faire pour
lancer ce dispositif
avec après la crise sanitaire et a été
constatée d'augmentation du nombre de
fédérations difficultés vous-même avez
précisé qu'il y avait aujourd'hui une 17
croix fédérations qui étaient en
difficulté ne disent le seront encore
l'année prochaine que quels sont les
actions les moyens qui sont programmés
pour venir soutenir et compagnie ces
fédérations qui sont qui connaissent
aujourd'hui des difficultés budgétaires
sur un plan sur le la formation initiale
des étudiants en médecine d'intégrer la
diversion sport santé dans les modèles
de formation et vous l'avez encore
précisé c'est un enjeu majeur de santé
publique qu'en est-il des
expérimentations sur l'accès au
remboursement de la prescription de sur
ordonnance de l'activité physique et
sportive dans une démarche thérapeutique
malheureusement ça fait des années qu'on
parle de ce sujet et toujours rien à
l'horizon ni sur les au niveau
budgétaires et pourtant c'était des
expérimentations qui ont été lancées
dans différents départements mais deux
dernières questions madame la ministre
ça concerne
les équipements que vous avez cités les
équipements structurants vous l'avez
vous-même souligné nous avons besoin de
travailler sur les équipements
structurants c'est le sens des travaux
d'analyse de l'agence pour bien voir les
endroits et sport qui doivent être
l'objet d'investissement prioritaire
vous avez signalé rappeler les 12
millions qui a été fait chez les
piscines par contre vous venez aussi de
préciser avoir une synergie avec le fond
de sobriété énergétique quelle est la
part sur le montant qui a été lancé
parce que on annonce la part globale
mais qui est la part qui va être fléchée
sur les équipements sportifs et
notamment des équipements aujourd'hui
qui sont en très grande difficulté c'est
les piscines sur les territoires avec
l'augmentation du prix de l'énergie et
les difficultés que rencontrent les
collectivités on voit de plus en plus de
piscine qui ferment qui réduisent leur
ouverture ce qui peut remettre aussi en
cause le développement de l'enseignement
du savoir nager qui est aussi une
priorité lorsqu'on voit le nombre de
noyaux par an et dernière question vous
avez parlé des 400 000 billets offerts à
la jeunesse au bénévole et au handicap
pour les Jeux Olympiques et
Paralympiques on a aussi
45000 volontaires qui vont être
mobilisés pour cette grande événement il
y a un problème qui qui surgit qui
aujourd'hui
fait obstacle peut-être à une volonté de
certains bénévoles notamment des autres
départements que la région la résine de
se postuler c'est la problème du
logement
quelle solution et qu'elle proposition
pourrait être fait pour permettre à tous
ceux qui veulent de toute la France
venir participer à ces grands événements
comme volontaires de pouvoir se loger il
y a une rareté du logement et surtout un
coup très élevé pour boire se loger donc
quelle est la est-ce qu'il y a une
solution et est-ce qu'il y a une
proposition sur laquelle vous travaillez
merci Claude Kern
merci monsieur le Président Madame le
Ministre merci pour votre présentation
alors c'est vrai que nous faisons
premier constat c'est le niveau inédit
de ce budget en hausse mais la question
qui se pose et Jean-Jacques Lauzac l'a
dit pour combien de temps
c'est vrai que cette hausse est
exceptionnelle on le voit étant vue des
Joop et beaucoup de questions restent
compte tenues des prochaines échéances
sportives majeures mais aussi en termes
de cohésion nationale de dynamisme
d'engagement de la jeunesse une grande
nation sportive se doit de passer par la
stabilité budgétaire et une vision plus
réelle claire pour tout le monde du
sport
et j'ai entendu votre
explication quant à la présentation
budgétaire sur les trois ans maintenant
nous attendons la démonstration par
l'État qu'il entend poursuivre son
effort après les jeux alors concernant
le programme 219 j'aurais quelques
questions tout d'abord en ce qui
concerne la promotion du sport pour le
plus grand nombre qui est la principale
action à bénéficier de la hausse des
crédits passeport
les simplifications apportées à la
rentrée 2022 doivent donc permettre
d'améliorer le taux de recours au
dispositif mais
ça a été évoqué pour l'instant ce
dispositif n'est pas tellement utilisé
question des crédits non consommés
consommés que fait-on y a-t-il un
redéploiement vers les associations
peut-être ou est-ce que ce dispositif ne
pourrait-il pas être élargi aux
fédérations sportives scolaires
ce qui concerne la ns nous avons un 11
millions d'euros supplémentaires pour
mieux structurer sa gouvernance et
amplifier son action territoriale
suite aux critiques de la Cour des
comptes comment abordez-vous cette
problématique j'essaie d'être
synthétique dans mes questions
puis en ce qui concerne les équipements
sportifs de proximité avec cette
nouvelle enveloppe dédiée 200 millions
d'euros concrètement comment le suivi du
programme des 5000 équipements sportifs
de proximité est-il envisagé notamment
dans le volet
héritage et si certains équipements vont
être rénovés pour être mis à la
disposition des GP ce n'est
malheureusement pas le cas des de la
majorité des équipements français qui ne
peuvent plus accueillir les
usagers dans des conditions décentes
sans parler de l'accessibilité aux
personnes en situation de handicap
comment envisagez-vous comment vous
engagez vous pardon sur
ces questions
et puis pour compléter la question de
mon collègue Michel Savin afin de
compléter donc le maillage territorial
des maisons sport centrée santé vous
avez affecté 4 millions d'euros
supplémentaires est suffisant pour un
aboutir pardon un maillage permettant
d'asserver l'accès de tous au sport et
puis là aussi ça a été rappelé les clubs
souffrent quels engagement ou plutôt
quelle garantie pouvez-vous déployer
d'autant que les performances de haut
niveau de même que les médailles au GP
viennent forcément des sportifs amateurs
à la base
en ce qui concerne le programme 350
note l'augmentation de 2,63% pour la
solideo pensez-vous que cette
augmentation soit suffisante contenue de
la hausse de l'inflation et puis pour le
kojob pareil un budget a été bâti sur
une hypothèse d'inflation de
1,4%. or on sait très bien que cette
dernière atteint
5,8%, comment allez-vous y répondre
comment allez-vous compenser et puis en
ce qui concerne l'héritage
en termes d'infrastructures mais aussi
et surtout en matière d'accompagnement
de la pratique sportive et d'insertion
par le sport
quel est votre approche et quel
financement complémentaire comptez-vous
déplorer déployer parce qu'on sait
souvent pour en avoir organisé à un
moment qu'après de grands événements
sportifs et ou autre réussite il y a une
période d'essoufflement qui vient
forcément après et c'est là qu'il faut
être présent pour éviter cette période
d'essoufflement et enfin j'en profite
pour vous poser une question de ma
collègue elles achailles qui est retenu
par une autre édition madame la ministre
le nouveau laboratoire antidopage a été
transférée je la lis à l'Université de
Paris Saclay ce laboratoire sera amené à
jouer un rôle très important lors des JO
de Paris 2024 la question concerne
l'équipement machine de ce nouveau
laboratoire nous le montant était estimé
à 11 millions d'euros dans le rapport de
l'année dernière de mon collègue
Jean-Jacques Lauzac qu'en est-il il
semble qu'il est un flou sur le
processus budgétaire et sur le
financement de ces équipements
pouvez-vous nous préciser si le
financement de ces
et bien prévu dans le budget et
pouvez-vous nous dire quels sont ces
moyens je vous remercie
Sabine oui merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre merci pour votre
présentation je ne voudrais pas jouer
les Cassandre devant les satisfaits
exprimées mais j'ai quelques inquiétudes
et où interrogations sur ces crédits
sports 2023 à vous soumettre donc
d'abord sur le le programme 350 jeux
olympiques et paralympiques le budget
initial qui était estimé à 6,6 milliards
d'euros et d'ores et déjà dépassé ce qui
n'est pas inhabituel mais je m'interroge
sur l'adage exprimée par le Président de
la République les jeux financent les
jeux sans argent public donc
qu'en est-il exactement
autre interrogation lien direct avec les
JO je m'étonne de la diminution de la
subvention à l'Agence française de lutte
contre le dopage alors que les contrôles
lors des compétitions sportives en cette
année près olympique devrait se
multiplier et enfin je me félicite de la
montée en puissance du dispositif
passeport
dispositif réclamé depuis de longues
dates par notre rapporteur est-il
envisageable de généraliser son
utilisation afin de contribuer à
l'amélioration urgente de la condition
physique de nos jeunes
il est primordial et vous l'avez dit que
la France devienne une nation sportive
et cela passe bien sûr par les nouvelles
générations je vous remercie
Thomas dessus
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre je vous ai bien écouté j'ai lu
la présentation de votre budget et en
réalité pas une fois vous avez cité ou
n'hésitez dans la présentation le mot
climat on a l'impression que l'horizon
de votre ministère c'est 2024 et après
tout peut brûler et le monde s'arrête
pas en 2024 et je pense qu'on a besoin
d'anticiper un peu ce qui peut se passer
et la première ministre avait annoncer
que chaque ministère aurait une feuille
de route climatique donc je m'attendais
à trouver quelques pistes dans ce budget
et on est un peu déçu là dessus en plus
on apprend dans le budget vert enfin que
le au sein du budget le sport fait
partie des 15 missions qui ne font pas
l'objet d'une fiche dédiée à la mesure
fiche mission dédiée au climat dans la
mesure où l'impact environnemental des
dépenses qui sont rattachés seraient
totalement neutre ce qui me surprend je
pense qu'on a un problème là
d'indicateur et on avait déjà évoqué un
peu ce grand vide dans la loi sport qui
était censé préparer le sport de demain
mais qui évitait déjà le sujet et
pourtant le sujet il est simple on
pratique pas le sport de la même manière
quand il fait 20 degrés ou 35 degrés et
il se matérialise sur façon très
concrète actuellement dans la dans les
factures énergétiques de nos
collectivités les équipements sportifs
prennent une place très importante et
50% des salles de sport ont été
construites avant 97 elles sont donc
inadaptées au fort de chaleur donc j'ai
bien compris qu'il y avait une deuxième
tranche de 50 millions pour aller plus
loin que les 2000 équipements rénovés
mais on voit que on a encore loin du
rythme
auquel il faudra aller par rapport au
rythme globalement climatique vous avez
annoncé des synergies avec le fond vert
mais comme l'a dit Michel Savin ça reste
encore assez flou et pourtant on a
besoin d'une feuille de route claire et
contrib budgétaire pour savoir comment
on adapte à la fois nos infrastructures
comme on finance le réadaptation mais
aussi comme on doit adapter nos saisons
sportives nos événements sportifs nos
pratiques et quels moyens on mettra sur
cette adaptation
mais on a pour l'instant pas beaucoup de
pistes budgétaires ni législatives et en
plus si j'ai bien compris vous allez par
votre présence aller cautionner la folie
climatique de la Coupe du Monde du Qatar
donc Madame la Ministre est-ce que votre
ministère va se pencher sur la question
climatique beaucoup sportifs ont compris
que leur pratique était en lien direct
avec l'évolution du climat et s'engage
personnellement on attend que le
ministère soit à leur côté sur cette
cause-là aussi le remercie Bernard
fialer
madame la ministre oui moi je reviendrai
pas sur sur tous les thèmes finalement
abordés ni surtout sur tout ce qui
touche
un domaine où il y a des sommes
indécentes pour reprendre le vocabulaire
qui vient de Mbappé moi je voudrais
m'intéresser presque à ce qui est une
niche mais qui représente quand même la
deuxième fédération sportive c'est le
sport scolaire et universitaire quand
même plus d'un million de participants
j'aimerais bien que vous précisiez quand
même ce que vous comptez faire pour pour
promouvoir ce sport scolaire et
universitaire
vous nous parlez beaucoup de la PQ je
moi aussi j'ai le même enthousiasme en
revanche sur ce que je constate j'espère
qu'il y aura des RTT et nos élèves vont
avoir des belles journées sportives en
fin d'année scolaire si on ne s'y met
pas plus vite partout vraiment les le
constat est important la pas aussi c'est
quelque chose d'important mais je pense
que la promotion du sport scolaire qui
touche encore
qui touche pourtant 40%
de fixe qui est bien et mais simplement
encore que 23% de des élèves et bien
devrait être plus mis en avant on a beau
être un peu spécialiste moi je suis
incapable par exemple aujourd'hui de
vous citer le nom d'un champion de
France universitaire d'un même d'un
champion du monde universitaire alors
que c'est quand même des exemples pour
notre jeunesse qui sont quand même
autrement plus étayant que
toute la publicité qu'on peut faire et
même les qu'on peut rendre à certains
autres champions je pense que montrer
qu'on peut faire une manière avec
excellence avoir des résultats sportifs
et que le temps libre soit consacré
finalement à faire des études c'est
mieux que de devenir champion d'isport
voire même quand on se livre pas
d'autres activités plus coupables ou
même quand on sert pas simplement de
promotion à des salons de coiffure
particulièrement atypique donc moi ce
que j'attends de vous c'est que
comptez-vous faire comme pour promouvoir
vous avez été une grande championne vous
avez fait des études brillantes je pense
que on doit porter davantage pour
permettre à notre jeunesse de faire du
sport et du sport scolaire universitaire
davantage ce domaine
je vais prendre toutes vos questions
Jacques gros Perrin
merci président madame la ministre j'ai
bien entendu écouter vos propos lorsque
vous dites que la France doit être une
nation plus sportive c'est-à-dire
qu'elle n'est pas si sportive en tout
cas j'espère que les résultats seront à
la hauteur et seront meilleurs que ceux
de romans 60 qui a fait que le Président
de la République à cette époque-là de
Gaulle véritablement mis en place un
grand plan sport ou éducation à l'école
je pourrais avoir plusieurs entrées dans
mes propos l'entrée la première entrée
c'est un très budgétaire vous y avez
répondu en expliquant en expicitant fort
bien ce budget qui est en hausse pour
couvrir sur tout cette montée en
puissance des Jeux Olympiques je crois
qu'un trompe l'oeil qui qui est là quand
même vous avez explicité aussi le
surcoût au niveau de l'aflation des
équipements mais il y aura aussi un
surcoût qu'il faudra pas négliger c'est
surtout au niveau de la sécurité qui se
qui se multiplie alors ce budget
suffit-il à rendre en tout cas le pays
sportif
et surtout à avoir cet été dit tout à
l'heure par notre sénateur et amis
Jean-Jacques Lauzac et Michel Savin
avoir un budget à la hauteur durablement
je crois que c'est ce mot qui revient
souvent durablement
à l'auteur des différentes ambitions
avec des services publics qui sont au
niveau départemental on voit en grande
difficulté alors en grande difficulté
est-ce aussi le fait que votre ministère
auparavant le ministère qui était géré
par le Jean-Michel Blanquer c'est un
ministère de l'Éducation nationale des
sports et de la jeunesse et cette
fois-ci c'est un ministère des Sports
que vous avez sous votre compétence et
l'éducation nationale et la jeunesse
sont à l'écart donc ces liens peuvent
parfois créer des difficultés au niveau
local ou national la deuxième entrée
c'est la complexité de ce mouvement qui
est on le voit dans des propos et dans
dans des lectures insoutables pour les
bénévoles employeurs parce que ils
disent tous qu'il y a des injonctions
chaque fois de l'état des injonctions
des régions qui sont souvent permanents
contradictoires toutes marquée de bonnes
intentions
donc je tiens à vous alerter mais en
tout cas après ces jeux de 2024
attention à ne pas trop demander et de
demander trop parce que je crois qu'il
faudra simplifier les choses et on sent
bien que que il y a une perspective en
tout cas il faudra qu'il y ait une
perspective de continuité éducative ou
une mise en concurrence des ressources
parce que lorsque vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure des deux heures des PS ou des 30
minutes on voit bien que c'est pas tout
à fait dans le même cadre et c'est
quelque chose qui me paraît très
important et enfin pour terminer le
président quand vous parlez d'habitude
vous faites référence bien sûr à
Bourdieu sur lequel nous avons tous
beaucoup travaillé mais attention à ses
habitudes là parce que les habitudes
font référence à un moment donné à des
habitudes de classe et il ne faudra pas
un moment donné discriminer une certaine
type de population pour les Jeux
Olympiques merci
oui je vais pas ajouter à tout ce que je
partage qui a été dit notamment par par
le rapporteur et par
ma collègue du groupe socialiste mais
très souvent il y a une expression
de rien lâcher et j'essaye de l'incarner
un petit peu avec vous
parce que
c'est important dans le débat que nous
avons je vous je en quelques une minute
vous dire pourquoi il faut arrêter de
négliger ça dans l'objectif qui nous est
commun de faire en sorte que
ce moment d'examen comme vous dites des
Jeux Olympiques soient
maintenant et ce moment un élan
populaire et un encouragement à la
pratique du sport c'est-à-dire que le
problème n'est pas de réussir à un
spectacle le problème est de s'en servir
comme levier pour
faire que le sport soit plus présent
dans la vie quotidienne des Français des
Françaises parce que c'est un élément
fédérateur mais c'est aussi un élément
pour la santé publique tout simplement
alors sa diffusion dans les masses
médias a toujours contribué
bien sûr il y a l'école l'éducation on
l'a dit donc ça vient se rajouter pas se
substituer à toujours contribué à cette
pratique
on se souvient que quand Yannick Noah a
gagné Roland-Garros ça a été un élan
gigantesque vers le tennis qui était un
sport réservé à quelques-uns à ce
moment-là on va dire par rapport à tous
les sports populaires etc et donc
la diffusion du sport dans les basses
médias est importante
tout ce que nous craignons y compris
quand j'ai remis ce rapport à la demande
du Gouvernement sur le fond qui était
que dans l'audiovisuel public qui a
cette mission le service public de
diffusion et du sport accessible et qui
peut justement choisir aussi des sports
peut connus et permettre cette diversité
se confirme de façon dramatique comme
vous le savez il ne reste plus que deux
événements importants sur le service
public
Roland-Garros c'est le tour de France et
Roland Garros est en train de passer
progressivement sous les fourches
codines d'Amazon
car vous savez que les offres qui seront
faites
France Télévisions ne pourra pas y
résister et que la fédération est
encline à pencher de ce côté-là de plus
en plus il y avait les matchs du soir
mais même le reste maintenant est en
discussion et je pense que la direction
de français des visions est très très
inquiète de cette situation pour les
amener à venir donc il y a rien de
sanctuariser on avait tout perdu sur le
service public et ce qu'on pensait être
acquis et menacé heureusement que le
Tour de France se fait encore en journée
pas la nuit parce que sinon on aurait
quelques soucis à se faire et donc je
vous répète ma question puisque vous
m'avez promis que la prochaine fois
qu'on se verrait ce serait réglé ce
décret que on m'a promis depuis
six ans je crois 2016
qui est un encouragement non seulement à
la diffusion du sport dans sa diversité
et donc
le sport féminin handisport mais aussi
le sport en clair et gratuit pour la
alors qu'il devient de plus en plus
payant où on a-t-on et pouvait vous
cette fois-ci me dire des choses que
vous tenez
de façon plus précise
je crois que ça s'appelle ne jamais rien
lâcher c'est ça
merci beaucoup merci pour
ces éléments à la fois d'encouragement
et de et de questionnements alors
peut-être pour prendre les points dans
l'ordre et je vais essayer de ne rien
oublier d'importance s'agissant du
passeport donc on a aujourd'hui en effet
un objectif de 2 millions de
bénéficiaires pour cette année versus
les 1,2 millions qu'on a pu enregistrer
au cours de l'exercice qui s'écoule à
date la dynamique est plutôt bien
engagée on a déjà 650 000 pas ce qui ont
été validées on avait démarré très fort
au début du mois de septembre avec une
hausse tendancielle de plus 45% puis
certaines difficultés une petite perte
de rythme c'est fait mais on est là en
train de reprendre l'avantage avec une
mobilisation du mouvement sportif avec
une communication digitale qui est
repartie vers les bénéficiaires on
s'appuie sur les associations sur les
collectivités et nous avons avec Sylvie
Retailleau lancé officiellement la
semaine dernière en étant à l'Université
Paris Nord de Bobigny le dispositif en
direction des étudiants boursiers on a
un travail de pédagogie à mener dans la
mesure où ce qu'on voit c'est que les
taux d'ouverture des emails reçus sont
très élevés autour de 90% mais le code
et lui assez peu utilisé à date donc
dans l'expérience et les différentes
étapes cet aspect d'entonnoir par lequel
on perd on a un petit peu de pertes en
ligne il faut qu'on arrive à mieux le
travailler pour que on puisse avoir une
couverture qui soit au rendez-vous de
nos objectifs s'agissant du dispositif
génération 2024 je suis très contente
que vous le ressouliez parce que c'est
pour moi un élément très important vous
savez qu'il y a derrière ce label 4
objectifs qui sont majeurs le fait de
développer des projets qui soient
structurants sur la pratique avec des
clubs du territoire le fait de pouvoir
participer à la semaine olympique
paralympique à la journée olympique à la
journée paralympique le fait aussi
d'accueillir ou bien de soutenir
d'accompagner des sportifs de haut
niveau et le dernier élément c'est
d'ouvrir les équipements sportifs des
établissements donc quand on regarde ces
quatre éléments on aurait envie que 100
% de nos établissements soient
générations 2024 et ne doutez pas un
instant que cette dynamique on va la
porter nous venons aujourd'hui de de
nommer une personne qui sera
spécifiquement dédiée à la promotion de
tous ces dispositifs en milieu scolaire
en lien avec la dynamique des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques et on va
absolument aller au-delà des 5000 écoles
et établissements qui aujourd'hui
impliquent à peu près 2 millions
d'élèves sur lequel il faut qu'aussi on
arrive à prolonger la dynamique sur
l'enseignement supérieur et aller
chercher ces centaines de milliers
d'étudiants pour bien les embarquer dans
cette dy pour nous c'est essentiel la
Semaine Olympique est paralympique à
l'école qu'on va avancer au mois de au
mois d'avril qui sera placé cette année
sous le signe de l'inclusion sera
vraiment un rendez-vous important pour
faire le point sur cette sur cette
dynamique de la labellisation
cyclisme comme l'équitation ou comme la
voile qui sont significativement
au-dessus de leur niveau d'avant crise
si je prends l'exemple de ces trois
disciplines avant crise 104000 pour le
cyclisme on est à 110 000 l'équitation
600 000 on est à 692000 la voie on était
à 220 000 on est à 265 000 c'est des
vrais ressauts qui sont très
intéressants on a certaines fédérations
je pense à l'athlétisme au basket au
volley qui souffrent encore un peu mais
qui ont quasiment retrouvé un cycle judo
leur niveau de d'avant crise donc
vraiment mon sentiment là-dessus c'est
que c'est vraiment un message
d'optimisme et de confiance retrouvée
pour un certain nombre de ces
disciplines
s'agissant de la formation
des médecins sur le sport santé je pense
que tous on a conscience que c'est l'un
des leviers les plus importants que nous
avons dans les années à venir puisque
depuis la mise en place du dispositif de
sport sur ordonnance par Valérie
Fourneyron c'est vraiment l'élément
culturel que nous devons parvenir à
mieux débloquer faire monter en
puissance et pour ça il faut agir à la
fois sur la formation continue de nos
médecins mais aussi je pense arriver à
intégrer un vrai module dédié dans la
formation dans les épreuves de
l'internat je pense que aujourd'hui
c'est le sens des échanges que j'ai avec
François Braun notre ministre de la
santé et de la prévention qui est
lui-même convaincu que c'est un passage
qu'il faut qu'on organise et donc on est
au travail pour le plus tôt possible
rendre cette aménagement effectif et
efficace
sur le point des équipements
structurants je peux que me rendre à
votre à votre remarque c'est cette même
ce même constat qu'à un moment il faudra
qu'on reprenne cette ligne là en main
que j'avais porté devant votre
commission le 12 octobre dernier
aujourd'hui mon sentiment c'est que on
fait vraiment le travail
aux deux bouts du spectre c'est à dire
sur les grandes enceintes sportives
c'est ce qui permet à notre pays pour
les Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
pouvoir s'appuyer sur 95% d'équipements
éphémères ou déjà existants et ce
travail majeur en termes
d'investissement 200 millions d'euros
sur les équipements de proximité pour
parvenir à en construire 5000 à travers
les disciplines sportives et l'ensemble
des territoires la dimension équipement
structurant elle n'est pas délaissée
aujourd'hui elle fait vous le savez très
bien puisque vous êtes un membre actif
du conseil d'administration de l'Agence
qu'un certain nombre de financements
leur sont consacrés mais il y aura la
d'avoir un regard très attentif en
sortie des jeux sur cette dimension là
de nos équipements pour le cas échéant
qu'elle est calibrer un plan de soutien
à cette dimension là
s'agissant des volontaires je vois que
vous êtes un
un supporter attentif de tout ce qui se
passe derrière ce programme ambitieux de
45000 volontaires
dont vous avez rappelé l'importance
aujourd'hui je voudrais vous rassurer
sur cette dimension du logement j'ai pu
vous rassurer la dernière fois sur la
dimension davantage en nature et
d'absence de requalification en
mentionnant le travail que nous menons
main dans la main avec les urssafs mais
aussi sur cette dimension donc du
logement vous indiquez que nous avons
lancé une mission conjointe des
différentes inspections notamment
l'inspection enfin l'IGA et Ligas sur le
recensement de l'ensemble des logements
mobilisables sur la France entière sur
des périmètres proches des épreuves pour
nos jeux olympiques et paralympiques et
en mettant bien dans le recensement des
besoins
l'ensemble des des une estimation des
volontaires qui pourraient être
concernées par ce besoin de et donc
d'hébergement donc je ne peux pas encore
vous répondre sur l'adéquation entre
l'offre et la demande estimée mais ce
que je peux vous indiquer c'est que les
volontaires sont parfaitement embarquées
dans les spécifications de cette mission
ils n'ont pas été du tout oublié en
termes de périmètre c'est un point très
important
alors
s'agissant donc de la de la de la
soutenabilité de de l'effort en
direction du sport un point que je
voudrais mentionner un peu en complément
de ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure sur
l'importance de ce de ce rendez-vous
des de 2024 et qui sera un moment
d'examen pour notre système en effet
comme l'a été Rome en son temps mais
simplement mentionné qu'on a tout un
travail sur l'évaluation à travers
12 à 15 champs qui sont couverts par ces
éléments d'évaluation et qui nous
permettront de montrer comment les
investissements réalisés depuis
plusieurs années notamment au titre de
l'héritage porte leurs fruits et
permettent d'atteindre les objectifs
qu'on se donne en termes d'évolution du
nombre de pratiquants en termes par
exemple du nombre d'enfants qui
enseignent syndic demain seront nager en
termes également d'inclusion de public
en situation de de handicap en terme de
dynamique de nos clubs sportifs donc on
sera avec une bonne évaluation en cette
fin d'année 2024 de l'efficacité des
leviers que nous avons activé et vous
avez raison de souligner qu'il y a des
pans de soutien à notre modèle sportif
qui sont devant nous je pense à ce que
vous avez dit sur le modèle
universitaire aujourd'hui on sait qu'on
a 70% de nos étudiants qui
souhaiteraient faire du sport mais
simplement 20% d'entre eux qui
parviennent et on a besoin d'avoir avec
Sylvie Retailleau les conclusions que
nous avons demandé
à l'inspection générale de l'éducation
du sport et de la recherche qui nous
livrera son rapport dans les semaines à
venir pour bâtir ensemble un plan de
soutien qui sera également
éclairé par les conclusions du rapport
récent de l'année STAPS qui a montré
qu'elles les freins à la pratique
étudiante en matière d'accessibilité
financière d'où le dispositif du
passeport ouvert aux étudiants boursiers
mais aussi en termes de diversité de
l'offre d'où la liaison que nous ferons
avec les schwaps les services unitaires
des activités physiques et sportives
dans des universités l'analyse de la
cévêque regardez comment cette
contribution volontaire elle a servi les
objectifs de développement de la
pratique sportive de la même manière que
nous développerons une logique d'audit
partenariale des équipements sportifs
universitaires avec ces mêmes
universités donc on sera vraiment en
mesure d'ici la fin d'année et ça fera
l'objet d'un atelier dédié probablement
au mois de février ou de mars selon la
méthode que j'ai défini des séminaires
IPCS impulsion politique et coordination
stratégique pour bien ficeler ce ce plan
dans le respect de l'autonomie des
universités et en partenariat avec elle
s'agissant toujours de cette thématique
de la soutenabilité budgétaire ce que je
voudrais également indiquer et c'est le
sens du travail qui est mené par la
digeste la Délégation interministérielle
aux grands événements sportifs c'est
aussi de s'assurer que petit à petit nos
grands événements développent des
modèles qui soient les plus innovants
possible et les plus équilibrés les plus
autoporteurs possibles à travers une
capacité un savoir-faire dans le fait de
trouver et d'engager des sponsors ou de
développer un certain nombre de de
création de richesse par exemple à
travers une meilleure animation de leur
programme de marketing de CRM avec les
personnes qui viennent sur ces
événements et au global d'accélérer sur
leur transformation digitale c'est pour
moi un élément important dans mon
message au sport c'est à dire que je
veux à la fois soutenir absolument son
développement sa résilience sa vit tant
sur le champ du développement de la
pratique que sur le haut niveau mais je
veux aussi un sport qui devienne plus
innovant plus moderne et qui trouve
aussi ces vecteurs de financement
notamment à travers cette organisation
de grands événements sportifs je pense
un élément très important cette capacité
que nous aurons de plus en plus à
mobiliser des entreprises et je souligne
que c'est d'ailleurs cette vision qui
est au cœur du modèle de l'Agence
nationale du sport puisqu'elle associe
le monde économique assez parti prenante
pour vraiment en faire un acteur à part
entière des politiques sportives demain
donc cette dynamique là il faut que nous
la fassions monter en puissance et un
autre ferment de durabilité c'est aussi
l'ambition que nous a donné le président
de la République n'ont pas seulement
d'essayer de performer le mieux possible
aux Jeux olympiques et paralympiques qui
arrivent mais également de nous inscrire
durablement dans ce Top 5 des nations
les plus médaillées ce qui porte en soi
un engagement de continuer à soutenir
autour des programmes ambitions bleus le
travail mené sur la haute performance
autour du plan coach autour du travail
sur les équipements sur les datas sur la
dimension scientifique et technique de
la préparation de nos athlètes en même
temps que nous les accompagnons sur le
volet du suivi socioprofessionnel et
également de la santé mentale qui sont
des enjeux très importants pour leur
donner la sérénité dont ils ont besoin
pour performer au meilleur de leur
capacité
s'agissant du du Pass sport je reviens
sur le point qui m'a à la question qui
m'a été posée de d'une éventuelle sous
budgétisation vous avez raison de
rappeler que l'an dernier c'est 40
millions qui étaient restés non
utilisées sur le budget du ministère qui
avait permis d'ailleurs de compenser à
hauteur de 20 millions d'euros la perte
de rendement de la taxe buffet et puis
les 20 millions de reports qui avaient
permis d'abonder les crédits de l'Agence
nationale du sport pour les centres de
préparation au jeu pour les projets
sportifs fédéraux ou bien pour le fond
de compensation des fédérations qui
avait notamment permis leur
modernisation l'accélération de leur
transformation digitale on ne se place
pas du tout dans cette perspective pour
cette année puisque vous l'avez entendu
nous avons vraiment un objectif
d'arriver à mieux trouver encore notre
site puisque il y a un gap entre le
nombre de personnes de jeunes qui ont
exercé leurs droits au passeport et le
nombre théorique de jeunes éligibles
notre pays qui est au nombre de 5
millions et nous avons ajouté notre
volet des étudiants boursiers donc l'un
dans l'autre le sujet est très bien
couvert aujourd'hui et il est très
vraisemblable que nous parviendrons au
100 millions d'euros qui sont prévus
dans ce budget au titre du programme 219
sur l'inclusion et le sujet du handicap
je voudrais souligner que au-delà des
efforts qui ont déjà été entrepris je
pense notamment à la mise en place d'un
taux de TVA réduit pour les matériels
sportifs
nous avons mobilisé des crédits pour
développer multiplier par quatre en
pratique le nombre de structures para-
accueillante à travers les territoires
où nous aurons des bénévoles et des
éducateurs formés pour recevoir
des
personnes en situation de handicap et
les aider à inscrire ça davantage dans
leur quotidien à un moment où on sait
que 48% d'entre eux sont aujourd'hui
éloignés de toute pratique sportive donc
cette dimension là sera aussi une
dimension d'héritage tout à fait
importante de la même façon que on
veille à l'accessibilité des équipements
sportifs et éminemment pour les jeux à
travers notre mobilisation avec les
membres et gen sur tout ce que nous
devons encore faire pour améliorer cette
accessibilité notamment le travail sur
les abords entre les gares et les sites
et au cœur des sites de compétition
sur le plan du maillage des maisons
sport santé je crois que donc les
crédits de 4 millions d'euros qui sont
prévus nous permettront de de finaliser
le maillage pour atteindre cet objectif
des 500 maisons sport santé qui avaient
été annoncées par le Président de la
République et qu'au-delà de ça ce qu'on
a besoin de faire c'est vraiment de
consolider ce réseau des maisons sport
santé en faisant en sorte qu'ils soient
véritablement un lieu de pratique pour
les personnes en situation d'ALD pour
les personnes en situation de maladie
chronique et aussi pour notre nouveau
public des seniors en perte d'autonomie
vous savez que c'est un élément ajouté
par la loi du 2 mars 2022 et nous avons
besoin que ces maisons sport santé
s'affirment comme des lieux accueillants
compris
identifiés dans les territoires et de la
même façon nous voulons que ces espaces
soient
des des vecteurs d'une meilleure mise en
réseau de l'ensemble des professionnels
qui œuvrent sur ce sujet du sport santé
en créant des passerelles qui
aujourd'hui n'existent pas suffisamment
notamment avec l'effet des rations
sportives qui derrière peuvent permettre
de développer une offre de sport santé
dans les clubs qui soient plus
performantes qui soit plus étoffée et
trouver des réponses pratiques aux
différents risques ou aux différentes
maladies que présentent les patients qui
sont aujourd'hui engagés dans ce dans
ces dynamiques de sport santé donc j'ai
envie de dire que pour conclure ce
propos le sujet n'est pas tant la
démultiplication des points que le fait
de consolider d'épaissir de solidifier
ce modèle pour qu'il puisse porter tous
ses fruits
alors sur l'hypothèse d'inflation manger
déjà pu répondre tout à l'heure aux
questions du du rapporteur Lauzac je
reviens en effet là-dessus donc pour
indiquer que en effet les budgets
avaient été construits sur une hypothèse
d'inflation de 1,4 % chacun comprenant
évidemment que sur une inflation qui est
aujourd'hui autour de 6%, on a des vents
contraires comme je les qualifié tout à
l'heure très important on est en train
d'affiner les chiffrages de regarder
d'ores et déjà l'inflation constatée sur
les mois écoulés et d'arriver à prévoir
le mieux possible sur des marchés
compliqués l'hôtellerie la restauration
la sécurité privée quelle va être
l'impact en peignant un à un les
différents contrats dans lesquels le
Kojo est soit engagé soit s'apprête
qu'il s'apprête à qu'il s'apprête à
opérer sur le marché il y a dans les
contrats déjà en des différences
notoires entre des clauses qui parfois
sont indexées parfois ne le sont pas
parfois le sont partiellement avec des
capages et donc tout ceci nous permettra
d'arriver au conseil d'administration
avec une hypothèse d'inflation qui sera
parfaitement documentée et un constat
d'ores et déjà sur les mois écoulés
depuis la dernière révision de ce que
nous aura coûté l'inflation en isolant
bien cette effets pris dans l'évolution
des dépenses du Kojo donc toute la
transparence sera faite sur cette
évaluation de l'inflation et de ces et
de ses impacts
sur le propos de la sénatrice Elsa
Schalke elle a raison de souligner que
aujourd'hui et ça fait d'ailleurs partie
des lignes que nous sommes en train de
réévaluer avec le Kojo nous avons besoin
sur le dopage et nous travaillons
ardemment ce sens je
j'évoquais le point avec Valérie
Fourneyron au titre de sa responsabilité
à Lama l'Agence mondiale antidopage en
travaillant également avec
l'AFLD pour que sur l'ensemble du
dispositif de test mais aussi sur les
spécifications des machines dont on va
avoir besoin à Saclay et puis sur les
contrôles officer c'est-à-dire
l'ensemble des personnes qui animent le
programme de lutte antidopage on soit
parfaitement au rendez-vous des
exigences portées conjointement par le
CIO et par Lama donc sur le sujet des
machines ça fait partie des points que
nous regardons pour trouver des
solutions de financement et nous prog
elles sont bien dans notre discussion
avec l'ensemble des parties prenantes
sur l'interpellation donc de la
sénatrice vanck sur les jeux finances
les jeux
je vous l'ai dit le travail et en train
d'être mené nous avons des étapes
importantes avec le bureau exécutif puis
le conseil et notre objectif est et
reste de pouvoir présenter un budget qui
soit le plus proche de l'équilibre
possible
pour cela j'ai l'évocat tout à l'heure
des discussions doivent être menées sur
le volet recette en allant à la
recherche d'un certain nombre de
partenaires et aussi avec le CIO pour
que le plus possible nous puissions
parvenir à cet équilibre mais je le
répète il y aura aussi des arbitrages à
rendre sur le volet des dépenses de
manière à équilibrer ce budget donc je
peux pas encore
à 2 novembre vous apportez les réponses
mais en tout cas le processus est mené à
bon train avec vraiment du lignaling et
l'ensemble des échanges programmés pour
nous permettre d'atterrir dans les
meilleures conditions possibles avec
l'ensemble des collectivités des partis
prenantes engagés le 12 décembre sur la
réponse à cette question sur la FLD
petite précision moi je n'ai pas une
contraction mais au contraire une hausse
de 1,5 millions de la subvention au
bénéfice de l'AFLD elle avait en effet
baissé sur l'exercice 2022 justement en
raison du transfert vers le laboratoire
de Paris Saclay mais sur
2023 nous sommes dans une légère hausse
des crédits qui sont affectés à l'agence
sur les conditions
[Musique]
j'ai noté conditions financières pour
les nos jeunes je pense que ça visait le
programme des deux heures pour les
collégiens que nous sommes en train de
bâtir c'est un dispositif que nous
expérimentons aujourd'hui
dans une
165 collèges à travers
64 pardon 34 académies et à peu près 90
de nos départements et qui fait l'objet
d'un financement de mon ministère pour
soutenir le travail des éducateurs
sportifs avec ces jeunes collégiens à
hauteur de 100 euros pour deux heures et
sur des groupes de vins collégiens donc
on est aujourd'hui en train avec
l'ensemble des fédérations de roder le
dispositif qui va commencer qui va
commencer à se mettre en place au
lendemain là des vacances donc à partir
de la semaine prochaine et qui va monter
en puissance jusqu'à Noël pour je
l'espère début 2023 nous permet d'avoir
déjà des meilleures pratiques à partager
et pouvoir prolonger cette
expérimentation et l'étendre à compter
de la rentrée de 2023
par rapport à l'interpellation de
Monsieur dos sur le sur le sur le climat
là je voudrais vraiment vous vous
rassurer et vous dire que je crois au
contraire que notre mobilisation sur cet
enjeu a été vraiment particulièrement
forte au cours des dernières semaines
vous l'avez suivi le 13 octobre dernier
nous avons publié un ambitieux plan de
sobriété énergétique qui avait été
retenu parmi les six plans portés
également par la première ministre lors
de ses pré-annonces du 6 octobre dernier
et là on nous avions pu nous le sport
être dans ce train des pré-annonces avec
la première ministre parce que justement
nous avions engagé un travail très
approfondi avec les collectivités
territoriales avec les fédérations et le
CNOSF mais aussi avec l'ensemble des
acteurs du sport professionnel qui nous
a conduit à proposer dans ce plan un
ensemble de mesures tout à fait
détaillées autour de de cette huile
exigences majeure tout ce qui est
sobriété en matière de chauffage et
d'éclairage
l'efficacité énergétique des équipements
sportifs l'enjeu évidemment de la
mobilité de la mobilité durable des
mesures qui ont trait à les
accompagnement et à la formation des
acteurs également des campagnes de
communication ambitieuse prévue l'enjeu
spécifique des piscines et puis la
dimension plus spécifique aux Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques tant du côté
du Kojo que de la solideo en même temps
que nous avons défini un plan de
réaction au signal et coat rouge et
lorsque j'ai fait ces différentes
annonces le 13 octobre dernier j'ai pu
annoncer deux autres volets très
importants de notre plan de transition
écologique tournée donc vers le fait
d'adresser cette tension issue de nos
dérèglements climatique mais aussi le
contexte lié à la géopolitique et aux
tensions incrémentales qu'il nous amène
en prévoyant avec Christophe la
production à l'horizon de mai 23 d'un
plan d'adaptation de la pratique
sportive au réchauffement climatique
donc nous avons missionné un expert qui
celui qui avait produit le rapport avec
le WWF pour montrer les enjeux et les
risques associés à ce réchauffement
climatique à la fois pour nos sports de
nature pour les activités pratiquées sur
le littoral par exemple et donc nous
avons pris l'engagement avec Christophe
béchudes produire ce plan qui est
d'ailleurs fera partie de l'héritage des
jeux et en effet d'anticiper par rapport
à l'été qui arrive et éviter de se
retrouver avec des activités sportives
très demandez d'énergie de rythmes
cardiaque à des heures impossibles d'un
point du point de vue de la chaleur donc
ça c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'extraordinairement important et le
deuxième pan que nous avons ajouté à ce
plan climat du ministère c'est la
généralisation de la Charte des
engagement éco-responsables avec d'ores
et déjà environ 70 acteurs qui sont
engagés derrière cette charte signataire
de cette charte et le CNOSF qui va nous
aider à avoir une cinquantaine de
signataires supplémentaires liés à une
transformation qui est qu'on n'aura pas
seulement des acteurs engagés dans cette
charte à l'occasion de l'organisation de
grands événements mais dans le cadre de
leurs activités quotidiennes
c'est-à-dire en tant quantité si je
prends un exemple c'est à dire que ça
n'est pas Roland Garros pour les 15
jours du tournoi mais c'est la
Fédération française de tennis dans son
ensemble
365 jours par an qui sera engagé dans
les mesures relatives à l'économie
circulaire à la gestion des déchets à
l'alimentation durable et à l'ensemble
de ces éléments qui nous permettent qui
vont nous permettre dans la durée de
baisser nos émissions en même temps
qu'on a évidemment un travail plus
structurel à mener sur la brique du de
sport dont on sait qu'elle est
massivement la source de notre empreinte
carbone ce qui fait que on a annoncé la
mise en place d'un groupe de travail
avec le sport professionnel et tout
particulièrement les clubs de foot et de
rugby pour avancer dans cette direction
et trouver de bons équilibres les
meilleurs possibles sachant qu'on doit
aussi concilier des impératifs de
praticité de coûts et de sécurité
associées
sur le sujet donc du du sport
universitaire je pense avoir monsieur le
sénateur filière répondu
en partie je voudrais simplement ajouter
que je partage absolument ce que vous
avez fait remarquer sur les championnats
du monde championnats de France
universitaire les championnats d'Europe
universitaire pour montrer que c'est une
dimension qui est très sous développée
dans notre modèle sportif par rapport à
ce que font les Américains mais aussi
les Allemands par exemple là donc j'ai
vraiment l'intention de pouvoir
accélérer sur cette dimension là et elle
passe par le travail que nous menons en
parallèle avec Sylvie Retailleau et
l'ensemble des fédérations pour une
meilleure insertion inclusion des
sportifs de haut niveau ou de bon niveau
dans nos universités vous avez en tête
qui a une instruction du 5 novembre 2020
qui prévoit toute une série
d'aménagements du tutorat du suivi du
livre idéalisé des aménagements horaire
la possibilité d'avoir des cours à
distance pour permettre à ces jeunes qui
ont une double passion et un double
cursus de faire leurs études dans les
meilleures conditions plus nos
universités seront peuplées de ces
profils là plus nous aurons de belles
équipes pour nous engager dans les
championnats universitaires et créer une
dynamique qui soit formidablement
inspirante comme ça l'est dans le
championnat universitaire américain qui
soit vraiment une locomotive et un sas
aussi parfois vers le sport
professionnel donc ce serait à tous
égards véritablement gagnant
il y a du travail
sur le chantier du eSport qui a été
mentionné je voudrais juste vous porter
à votre connaissance donc le baromètre
le huitième baromètre du eSport qui a
été présenté hier par France eSport et
qui est très rassurant sur la pratique
sportive on va dire classique à défaut
d'un meilleur mot des sports
amateurs donc il faut vraiment pas qu'on
soit en train d'opposer des e-sportifs
qui seraient par trop sédentaire à des
sportifs au contraire on voit que ils
sont à 86% pratiquant d'une activité
sportive une à trois fois par mois ce
qui fait deux des on va dire un groupe
témoin
plus engagé dans l'activité physique et
sportive que le reste de la population
c'était pour moi une des trouvailles
très importantes et très positive de ce
de ce baromètre
alors
le sénateur donc opéra évidemment raison
de de mentionner au titre des surcoûts
des jeux les enjeux qui sont sa tâche à
la à la sécurité notamment à la sécurité
privée je l'évoquais tout à l'heure on
sait que ce sont des métiers en tension
cette revalorisation qui a été annoncée
par la filière de 7,5% des salaires dans
cette profession et la nécessité que
nous allons avoir d'investir pour
permettre une meilleure formation et
notamment de la part des étudiants les
engager dans le titre de sécurité
événementielle qui a été créé et qui
doit nous permettre d'arriver à créer
toutes ces petites rivières qui
permettront de rejoindre le flux des
agents de sécurité privée que nous avons
besoin aussi de remobiliser autour de
cet enjeu je rappelle que nous aurons
besoin au pic de 25 000 agents de
sécurité privée pour nos jeux olympiques
et paralympiques c'est donc un enjeu qui
est tout à fait tout à fait essentiel
dans la réévaluation de nos besoins pour
les jeux
j'espère ne pas avoir oublié de points
majeur alors
mais monsieur
vous pouvez le signer en direct qui sera
ravi
de temps que
j'ai encore
j'ai encore quelques étapes importantes
à franchir avant de pouvoir arriver
à l'objectif de la sortie de ce de ce
décret donc je rappelle peut-être
d'abord que nous avons reçu en début
d'année les 15 contributions de la part
de l'arcom des éditeurs de services de
télévision gratuit payant des
distributeurs et aussi des fédérations
sportives je pense à celle du tennis
qu'il a mentionné et également à celle
du du ski on est aujourd'hui avec Rima
Abdul Malak que je vois exactement sur
ce sujet demain dans une logique de
valider un certain nombre de
modifications qui nous permettront de
laisser plus de place en clair aux
éléments relatifs au paraport et au
sport féminin l'étape ensuite que nous
devons franchir c'est la notification de
cette liste modernis à la Commission
européenne qui est une procédure
préalable et obligatoire avant qui est à
nouveau une saisine de l'arcom et du
Conseil d'État pour modifier le décret
du 22 décembre 2004 les indications que
j'ai requises parce que je voulais avoir
une réponse précise pour le sénateur
Assouline c'est que la modification de
notre décret interviendrait entre le T2
de l'année le deuxième trimestre de
l'année 2023 et au plus tard la fin du
T3 2023 pour ça il faut qu'on appuie on
puisse accélérer le regard que doit
apporter la Commission européenne et on
va s'y employer avec l'aide de nos
équipes à Bruxelles mais je voudrais
souligner que évidemment ce qu'on a
besoin de faire c'est de trouver le
meilleur équilibre possible puisqu'on
sait aussi que les éléments de droit de
diffusion sont une ressource tout à fait
importante pour les acteurs du sport et
donc la nécessité comme comme je le
disais aussi de préserver et de
travailler sur des modèles économiques
qui soient porteurs qui soient
générateur d'autonomie pour notre
mouvement sportif peut-être une bonne
nouvelle que je voulais partager c'est
que dans le rapport de l'arcom qui a été
publié dans les dernières semaines on
voit que le poids des contenus sportifs
qui ont été diffusés en télévision
gratuite a augmenté de plus de quatre
points puisqu'il est passé de 1,2 % à
5,4% entre
2012 et 2020 donc moi je vais être
évidemment vigilante à ce qu'on trouve
le meilleur équilibre économique
possible entre la disponibilité des
offres à un cours raisonnable pour les
téléspectateurs et le développement
économique des ayants droits qui est
également une dimension importante et je
précise en rebond de ce que de ce à quoi
m'inviter à commenter le rapporteur
lausak tout à l'heure sur les taxes
affectées que aussi la taxe buffet qui
assure cette jonction cette solidarité
financière entre le sport professionnel
et éminemment le sujet des diffuseurs de
la diffusion payante et le sport amateur
à hauteur de 5% du montant hors TVA de
l'ensemble de ses droits de diffusion
donc on a un modèle qui est bien pensé
et qui permet d'organiser cette juste
complémentarité
je fais une dernière question à vous
poser madame la ministre elle est pas en
lien avec le projet de loi de finance
mais avec l'actualité la semaine
dernière le ministre de l'Intérieur
devant notre commission et celle des
lois nous disait que pour assurer la
sécurité pendant les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques et permettent la
mobilisation des forces de sécurité il
faudrait
reporter ou annuler un certain nombre de
manifestations culturelles mais aussi
sportives je voulais savoir si vous
aviez commencé de travail
d'identification des manifestations
sportives qui devraient être soit annulé
soit reporté et notamment est-ce que des
échanges ont déjà eu lieu sur avec un
Esso sur le Tour de France ou
éventuellement avec la Ligue
professionnelle de football sur le
championnat qui démarre si je demande
trompe pas en août d'habitude
alors c'est donc en effet un moment
important que nous
organisons aujourd'hui avec le ministre
de l'intérieur avec la ministre de la
Culture qui d'ailleurs au moment même où
on se parle est en train d'amorcer une
première phase de concertation avec les
festivals nous travaillons avec
l'ensemble des préfets et la dijob
coordonne un exercice de recensement qui
sous l'autorité du cabinet de la
Première ministre nous conduit à
regarder deux périodes complémentaires
celles qui va finalement correspondre à
la période du relais de la flamme et
celle qui va démarrer autour du 23 du
autour du vin à peu près juillet qui
correspond à l'ouverture du village
olympique et paralympique et jusqu'au 8
septembre qui est la date de clôture des
Jeux paralympiques donc ce travail de
recensement il est en train d'être
consolidé on regarde là aussi dans
l'ensemble des territoires ceux de ces
événements qui nécessitent des forces de
sécurité
pour pour pouvoir optimiser absolument
la répartition de l'effort dans les
événements culturels et sportifs qui
vont correspondre à la première période
on va pouvoir assez largement maintenir
ces événements là mais il faudra
réfléchir à des éléments d'aménagement
de leur format parfois de leur
emplacement parfois
sur le cahier des charges etc et c'est
en revanche sur la seconde période que
là on aura certainement besoin d'ajuster
les dates de les différer de les avancer
ou d'envisager l'annulation pour ceux de
ces événements où on aura pas d'autres
solution que de le faire mais je précise
que c'est vraiment l'ensemble des
paramètres que nous regardons c'est à
dire à la fois les besoins en force de
sécurité mais aussi les tensions qui
peuvent se s'exprimer sur les matériels
également les besoins par exemple en
secouriste donc c'est vraiment
l'ensemble de ces éléments là qui
aujourd'hui sont regardés
et qui vont faire l'objet de
concertation d'un travail mené en local
avec les ministres concernés et avec
chacun des préfets au cas par cas pour
trouver les meilleures solutions
possibles le sport sera affecté vous
avez mentionné le Tour de France
masculin nous aurons probablement besoin
d'avancer ce calendrier du Tour de
France masculin nous aurons aussi besoin
de trouver une solution pour le Tour de
France féminin qui va se retrouver lui
complètement dans la zone de
corresp au jeu olympiques et nous allons
aussi avoir besoin de travailler avec
les leads professionnels tant de rugby
que de foot pour l'aménagement du
calendrier des compétitions sur le sur
le mois d'août nous aurons également un
certain nombre de compétitions cycliste
qui seront à ajouter avec des
championnats sur route donc c'est tout
ça que nous sommes en train de recenser
la concertation va se faire elle va
s'ouvrir et avec la nécessité de trouver
le meilleur équilibre entre préserver au
mieux
la répartition optimale de nos forces de
l'ordre dont je rappelle que le ministre
de l'Intérieur les mobilise à plein avec
pas de période de congés pendant toute
cette période estivale la mobilisation
en renfort des réservistes donc c'est
vraiment un investissement très
important mené par le ministère de
l'intérieur et en même temps la
nécessité de trouver tant pour les
acteurs sportifs que culturel tous les
aménagements de manière pragmatique au
cas par cas avec les préfets sur le
terrain pour que l'économie de ces
événements soit la plus préservée
possible
merci
les nombreuses réponses que vous avez
apportées à nos questions et donc nous
nous retrouvons dans quelques jours dans
l'émission pour
l'examen et le vote surtout sur les
crédits du sport merci beaucoup je vous
remercie beaucoup merci